bonjour à tous
comment je me suis retrouvé ici
aujourd'hui devant vous sur la scène du
tedx
le 17 janvier dernier
en baladant sur instagram pour la 15e
fois de la journée je suis tombé sur une
publication de l'iae lyon qui offrait
l'opportunité aux étudiants de
participer à un concours d'éloquence
après avoir fait face à de nombreux
jours d'hésitation donc je vous
épargnerai les détails j'ai finalement
décidé de participer à ce concours
le futur vainqueur de ce concours allait
avoir l'opportunité d'être ici devant
vous aujourd'hui
sur six
le thème de ce concours d'éloquence
était le retournement de situation je me
suis donc posé la question que
représente réellement un retournement de
situation
sujet compliqué à la fois la réponse
semble évidente est à la fois l amener à
une certaine réflexion
j'avais donc deux choix possibles soit
j'ai décidé de prendre le sujet au pied
de la lettre en cherchant à tout prix a
présenté un discours avec un
retournement de situation de dingue pour
impressionner un maximum les jurys
soit décidé de creuser un peu plus le
sujet en essayant d'aller réellement
chercher ce qui se cachait derrière
alors je m'étais renseigné pour faire
apparaître une équipe de ninja brésilien
dans la salle
et pour des raisons évidentes j'ai
plutôt choisi de réfléchir par moi même
quoi qu'il en soit j'ai fait ce que
n'importe qui aurait fait ma place j'ai
tapé concours d'éloquence tedx sur le
retournement situation sur youtube et
sans surprise je tombais sur des smiths
philosophe qui utilisent des noms ou des
mots compliqués pour parler de sujets
compliqués j'ai donc plutôt choisi de
réfléchir pour moi même
je me suis donc posé la question dans un
premier temps qu'est-ce qui aujourd'hui
pour tout le monde peut être considéré
comme un retournement de situation
et j'ai trouvé le premier confinement
personnellement pendant le premier
confinement je me suis donné comme
objectif d'une part de trouver quelque
chose de plaisant à faire et d'autre
part qui me permettrait de gagner un peu
d'argent
je me suis donc rapidement tourner vers
des solutions faciles comme par exemple
répondre à des sondages rémunérés ce qui
me permettrait à la fois de gagner un
peu d'argent est à la fois très sensible
dans mon lit
malheureusement
application qui promettent de l'argent
facilement on se rend vite compte que ce
n'est rien de plus qu'une illusion
c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé de me lancer
et j'ai fait les démarches afin de
devenir auto entrepreneur est j'ai mon
prêt j'ai monté ma propre activité la
livraison à domicile
venu livrer au brit
alors oui c'est vrai quand je fais mes
livraisons jeu ressemblait un peu un
sixième qui viennent acheter son tout
nouveau sac à dos
mais au moins ça m'a permis d'être
indépendante financièrement pendant
l'été et ça ça a été pour moi un réel
retournement de situation
donc là vous allez dire que je m'égare
un petit peu du sujet mais je m'en suis
rendu compte en écrivant ce tedx le plus
dur c'est pas d'écrire sur un thème
le plus dur c'est de se l'approprier en
essayant d'aller transmettre un message
qui va potentiellement inspirer les
autres
alors dit comme ça ça fait un petit peu
gourou d'une secte je vous la corde mais
je vous assure que c'est pas du tout ça
prenons un exemple je m'appelle paul
j'ai 19 ans et je suis actuellement en
deuxième année à l'iae en licence
management des sciences humaines dans la
vie je ne considère pas réellement
différent des autres étudiants de ma
génération c'est à dire que je râle
quand la cour parce qu'il faut aller à
la fac je râle quand y'a pas court parce
que je fais la fête pour rien bref rien
qui pourrait faire de moi quelqu'un de
bien différent
pourtant
en voyant l'opportunité de ce concours
d'éloquence je me suis rendu compte
d'une chose depuis tout petit j'ai
toujours été à l'aise à l'oral
j'ai toujours aimé les grandes
discussions que ce soit entre amis en
famille bref j'ai toujours été à l'aise
à l'oral
pourtant dès qu'il faut intervenir en
public ou dans des personnes que je ne
connais pas ça se complique
je suis it ans j'ai plus trop confiance
en moi
alors j'ai d'abord essayé de trouver des
solutions à court terme pour résoudre ce
problème
d'abord il ya l'alcool
même si on se rend vite compte que
l'image qu'on renvoie n'est pas
forcément celle qu'on aimerait renvoyé
et puis surtout ce n'est pas une
solution qui est fiable à long terme
alors assure thomas me quand je parle
d'alcool c'est uniquement dans un cadre
festif et occasionnels
je parle pas attaquer la vodka 7 heures
du matin pour être sûr de ne pas
paniquer quand on m'interroge danser
et puis je me suis rendu compte que le
plus dur dans tout ça pour oser créer
son retournement de situation c'est
justement le fait d'oser
alors le fait d'oser c'est ce qui a
permis à steve jobs et steve wozniak en
1976 de se lancer dans le garage de
leurs parents pour créer ce qu
aujourd'hui devenue apple l'entreprise
de technologie la plus viable au monde
qui pèse plus de 3000 milliards de
dollars
le fait d'oser
c'est également ce qui a permis à walter
héroïne disney en 1923 de se lancer
toujours dans le garage de leurs parents
pour créer ce que sont devenus
aujourd'hui les dessins animés les plus
vues de tous les temps avec des films
comme le roi lion ou la reine des neiges
qui ont chacun récolté plus d'un 1,5
milliard de dollars de recettes
malheureusement pour moi je n'ai pas de
garage donc ça risque d'être compliqué
pour moi mais tout ça pour dire que le
succès de ces entreprises est due au
fait qu à la base ils ont osé tenter
leur chance
je me suis donc posé la question
qu'est-ce qui aujourd'hui peut empêcher
à tant de personnes de se lancer dans un
projet qui leur tient à coeur
j'ai trouvé deux raisons la première
c'est la peur du regard des autres
inscrirait ce concours d'éloquence je ne
cache pas que j'ai un petit peu hésité
pour la première sélection il fallait
envoyer une vidéo de soi on se filmer
pendant cinq minutes
en disant des choses sur le retournement
de situation
alors le fait d'écrire en soi n'était
pas le plus compliqué en revanche le
fait de se filmer avec une pile de sept
livres entassés pour essayer d'avoir une
hauteur de correct sur la caméra je ne
vous cache pas que j'ai le temps de me
dire deux fois qu'est ce que je suis en
train de faire
et puis en fait je me suis rendu compte
que ce dont j'avais le plus peur c'était
la réaction qu'elle est avant les jurys
en regardant ma vidéo
et puis j'ai décidé de passer outre et
de me lancer parce que je savais que
dans tous les cas quel que soit le
résultat cette expérience ne pourrait
être que bénéfique pour moi et l'avenir
me l'a bien prouvé
la seconde chose qui selon moi peut
empêcher attendre personne de se lancer
à fond dans un projet c'est la peur de
l'échec
en faisant des recherches sur la peur de
l'échec de manière générale je suis
rapidement tombé sur le cas de jean
tooling
alors jk rowling avant de devenir
l'écrivain à succès de la saga la plus
vendu du 21e siècle traduit en plus de
80 langues et vendu à plus de 500
millions d'exemplaires dans le monde on
peut dire qu'elle a connu l'échec
déjà c'est dans un contexte de grande
précarité qu'elle écrira son premier
roman à l'école des sorciers
durant cette période elle se mariera
avec un homme violent avec lesquels elle
aura une fille
un an plus tard
se séparer de cet homme et partira vivre
en écosse avec sa fille sous les aides
du gouvernement
elle se verra ensuite refusé
successivement son roman auprès de douze
éditions 12 maisons d'éditeurs avant de
signer avec la maison d'édition
bloomsbury
rires mais sans se tromper que cette
femme est plutôt bien placé pour parler
de l'échec dans une conférence qu'elle a
tenu à harvard lors de la remise des
diplômes des élèves jk rowling leur a
donné des conseils afin de surmonter
cette possible peur de l'échec qui
pourront connaître dans leur vie
alone et donc plusieurs conseils et je
vais vous livrer les deux qui ont le
plus retenu mon attention
le premier c'est celui-là
chercher à plaire à tout le monde c'est
le meilleur moyen d'une pierre à
personne
quand on a 20 ans on est confronté à
deux choses
d'une part on cherche à remplir nos
parents à faire des études à être
épanoui afin qu'ils soient fiers de nous
et d'autre part on cherche à mener des
décisions
quiconque ils feront de nous la personne
qu'on sera plus tard
confronté à faire des choix comme par
exemple révisé partiel ou sortir en
boîte
mais quoi qu'il en soit je pense que ces
choix c'est important de les assumer à
100 % et de ne pas chercher à faire des
compromis car en fait en faisant des
compromis ont satisfait en fait
réellement jamais personne y compris soi
même
le second conseil qu'elle a donnée aux
étudiants c'est celui-là l'échec est
inévitable et peut-être libérateur je
pense qu'une fois qu'on est conscient de
ça une fois qu'on est conscient que quoi
qu'on fasse et qui conçoit dans la vie
on connaîtra forcément l'échec un moment
donné
mieux vaut le connaître le plus tôt
possible pour savoir se relever et
apprendre de ses erreurs
je t'aime une raison par une citation de
coluche qui selon moi résume assez bien
mes propos sur le fait que pour oser
créer son propre rendement situation
oser changer c'est déjà la première
étape
c'est d'oser
sans forcément tenir compte du regard
des autres ou encore de la peur des
chèques
cette citation c'est la suivante
la vie mettra des pierres sur ta route
fera un mur
ou un pont merci de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]